Given a matrix, how do we find its adjoint?
This is a two-by-two matrix 'A', and we need to find its adjoint.
This is a new term and maybe slightly confusing.
But it will be easy, if you concentrate well for the next two minutes.
To find the adjoint we first need to find some matrix.
What is this some matrix?
It will be of the same order as the original matrix.
So we need to find the four elements here,
Each element will be the cofactor of the corresponding element
from the original matrix.
So here we will have the cofactor of the one oneth element.
Here, we will have the cofactor of the one twoeth element and so on...
Once this matrix is done,
we need to find its transpose and that will give us the adjoint of "A".
We find the cofactors first and then find the transpose of this matrix.
The first element is two.
What will be its cofactor?
It will be 'negative 1' raised to '1 plus 1' multiplied by its minor.
1 and 1 are the row number and column number of 2.
What will be its minor?
We exclude the row and the column,
and find the determinant of what remains.
That will be the Minor. The determinant of 3 will be 3.
So this would be multiplied with 3, this is the cofactor of 2.
'Negative 1' raised to 2 is 'positive 1',
and 1 multiplied with 3 will equal 3.
3 is the cofactor of 2.
Next we find the cofactors of 5 ,1 and 3 .
The element 5 lies in the one twoeth position.
So we multiply 'negative 1' raised to '1 plus 2' with its minor.
To find the minor of 5.
We exclude row 1 and column 2
and find the determinant of what remains..
The determinant of 1 is 1.
1 is the minor of 5. So we multiply this with 1 to get the cofactor.
Negative 1 times 1, will give us negative 1.
Negative one is the cofactor of five.
Now pause the video and try to find the cofactors of one and three.
We get the cofactor of one as 'minus 5'. And that of three as two.
These are the four cofactors we found.
Now we could write this matrix down,
three, minus one, minus five and two.
We have to find the transpose of this matrix.
So we mark a slant line here ! This will be the adjoint of 'A'.
Do you remember how to find the transpose of a matrix?
Yes, we interchange the rows and the columns.
The first row will become the first column,
3, minus 1 and the second row will become the second column,
minus 5, 2.
That's the adjoint of matrix 'A'.
Find the cofactors first,
and then find the transpose of the resulting matrix.
We will understand a few more examples in the next part of the session.